and when i went through depression
afterwards i was a different person than
i was before
and i and i feel more um
grounded now than i did then
and i probably relate
to the artists who so many of the
artists i work with suffer so many
artists suffer because that's part of
what makes an artist great is their
level of sensitivity
that the same thing that makes uh an
artist uncomfortable other people don't
feel at all
the time you were
depressed
what was the darkest moments of your
life what took you there how did you get
out
it was triggered by a
person making a comment about something
to do with work
that didn't matter you know it was like
to anyone else
they would hear that and it would just
be like okay we'll deal with it next
week whatever but for some reason i took
it in a way that um
i felt
like the rug had been pulled out from
under me even beyond the rational part
of it of understanding
you know even after the problem that
came up was solved it somehow
undermined something in me
and made me feel very vulnerable in a
way that i hadn't felt before
and it spiraled how did you get out
i did a lot of different kinds of
therapy i did um
starting with alternative therapies i
was seeing
i would say
between seven and eight
doctors and or therapists a week
um
acupuncture
talk therapy
um
herbs or any any possible modality tried
everything for a long time
and um
and and nothing seemed to
have an impact and then finally um
i'm
wary of taking any western medicine
i'm not a drug taker
and or drinker or
partier in any
way
and um
i found uh
a psychopharmacologist who was a psychic
but because she was a psychic i was okay
to see her because like i'll i'll do
i'll listen to a psychic but i'm not
going to listen to a
psychopharmacologist
but the fact that she had the the
psychic
that made her fit into my worldview
and um
and she recommended antidepressant which
went terribly wrong in the first night
that i took it
and then i that set me on a journey of
looking for the right antidepressant
which was a long and painful process of
a journey everyone that i took made me
sick
everyone and then finally
i don't know five months later six
months later
i found the magic one that worked for me
and it um
it shifted me out of the depression i
took it for my camera was six months or
a year
and then weaned off and was okay and
then i had another event some years
later
i think i took it again for a short
period of time
and got out of it and i've not needed it
since were you able to
kind of introspect the triggers that led
to the events
is there some or is it
random events of life i think it's more
that um
because of the way that i grew up
i never had to deal with much
controversy
and um
when i when i was challenged
i didn't have any
ability to deal with it it's like um you
know jonathan height talks about
it's like that
so you actually also mentioned like
business sometimes gives you stress so
these this was business related stuff
yeah it was a business related thing it
just made me feel bad
you